he's now my husband
what yes you did
you guys anna ferris and michael barrett
are married oh my god
no way the actress accidentally spilled
the beans that she and the
cinematographer
secretly eloped on the latest episode of
her on aferis's unqualified podcast
he's now my husband
what yes we are you did
you guys i'm sorry i didn't know if i'm
sorry honey i just blurted that out but
it just
like i can't say fiance anymore while
the news is a small surprise the fact
that the couple eloped isn't check out
what anna told et
just a couple years ago do i have any
advice for anybody out there getting
married no
no hello maybe but back to the podcast
anna detailed their intimate nuptials
held at a courthouse
it was great it was san juan island up
in washington state
which is like the most magical place on
earth the former mom star added that she
accidentally revealed the marriage in a
similar way to her family
we saw my family and it kind of slipped
out the same way
my aunt asked me you are going to be a
stepmom how are you feeling about that
and they said
well actually i am a stepmom as of like
four days ago
but it oh great everything about it just
felt right
the happy news just confirmed
speculation sparked after anna was
spotted wearing a ring on that finger
while out to dinner with friends over
the weekend it's incredible
this is the third marriage for the
actress she was previously with ben
indra from 2004
to 2008. honey i i
i want to thank you for being the most
incredible person
a year later she said i do to chris
pratt they share eight-year-old jack
you know they get to an age where the
obnoxious things stop being cute
like first when they draw on your wall
and you're like oh yeah that's kind of
charming because my kid might be an
artist
and then when they do it later five and
a half
they're like no no not so cute
anymore anna and chris announced their
split in 2017
after eight years of marriage not long
after anna and michael were first
spotted together
i'm i'm so thrilled and get this
accidentally breaking news about the
relationship
runs in the family well the tv family
last year anna's mom co-star allison
janney recalled spilling the beans about
ana's engagement to e.t
we just recently found out anna was in
gay anna is engaged
i i think i like you spill the meat i'm
not sure if i was supposed to spill the
beans because i'm not i don't always
follow up on everything
and someone asked me and on the red
carpet are you happy about ana's
engagement and i was like of course
i don't think it was mine it's not a bad
thing well maybe not but it's not a bad
thing
i think it was my news to share so i
think from here on and i'll let anna
speak about her life
and i will speak about all i know is
that i love her very much
and we're very happy for you that's it
that's it that's a wrap